this is what the pre-visuals of  spider-man no way home looked like  before they filmed anything and you can  spot a couple of deleted scenes here you  can see spider-man overlooking new york  city his fight with doc ock was gonna  have an extra bit of fighting up on the  street sign the first encounter with  elektro is shown to have a longer fight  that featured a giant version of the  villain the fight in the mirror  dimension was going to have an extended  sequence of doctor strange and peter  fighting for the box and the trains  forming into a spider web the final  battle at the statue of liberty was  going to have doctor strange cast a  large protection shield have electro  shock the head of the statue and see the  spider-man perform some more combo moves  while explosions go off around them it  also included doctor strange getting in  on the action with some sweet dance  moves  [Music]